BUKOLA AYODELE:
Compliance audits
can be arduous, painstaking,
time consuming tasks.
Let's see how Policy
Controller simplified Oma's job
enough for her to leave work
before dinner time on an audit
day.
Its audit day.
And as people responsible
for performing audits know,
this is a time
every month when Oma
feels overwhelmed,
because she needs
to review whether the entire
company's infrastructure is
compliant.
This typically
involves many hours
of reviewing configurations,
meetings with team leaders,
and analyzing running
infrastructure to make
sure everything is compliant.
A lot of the time spent
tracking down potential problems
would disappear if there is a
way to automatically enforce
correct policy instead
of having to track down
possible compliance issues.
It would be better to have
a system that stopped them
from occurring in
the first place.
Oma heard a lot
about the new tools
that Charlie's team
introduced and is
wondering if those tools
can possibly help them.
After hearing their
issues, Charlie
explains Policy Controller
and how it can not only
ensure compliance,
but also enable
audit logging of violations
that were uncovered
when policies were introduced.
Oma is intrigued
to say the least.
Policy Controller is a
Kubernetes dynamic admission
controller that checks, audits,
and enforces your cluster
compliance with policies related
to security, regulations,
or arbitrary business rules.
Policy Controller enforces
cluster compliance
with policies
called constraints.
Constraints are a
powerful feature
that allow for fine grain
control over a cluster.
For example, you can enforce
many of the same requirements
as pod security policies,
but with the added ability
to audit your configurations
before enforcing it.
You can limit the
type of volumes
that can be mounted
to pods, or even
control the repository a
given container image can
be pulled from, and more.
Along with constraints,
Policy Controller
also introduces
constraint templates.
These allow you to define how a
constraint works with delegate
defining the specifics
of the constraints
to an individual or group
with subject matter expertise.
In addition to
separating concerns,
this also separates the
logic of the constraints
from its definition.
So for example, if you have
a family of applications
that will have to use a
limited range of ports,
you can define a template
like this to limit the range
but define that range with a
constraint at implementation
time.
Oma's team decides
to start requiring
labels on namespace that specify
who the namespace owner is.
This is a good use of the K8s'
required labels constraints.
In order to start using Policy
Controller to add a required
label, Oma first creates
a corresponding constraint
with the dry run mode set.
This allows Oma to
monitor all the violations
without causing downtime.
Once this constraint is
applied to the cluster,
Oma can view the
audit by looking
at the constraint object logs.
She now has a list of teams
and services to talk to.
After they fix the issues, she
removes the enforcement action,
which means the default
enforcement actions [INAUDIBLE]
takes effect, even stop,
further policy violations
from occurring.
In the past, she used
to have to follow up
with teams individually
to retroactively track
down and fix policy violations.
Now, with Policy
Controller, Oma has
a list of violations and a way
to block them from occurring.
Policy Controller using a
familiar GitOps approach
to enable policy
rules for existing
conflicts and logs violations
that do occur once enabled.
And best of all, because
of Policy Controller,
Oma got to be home
before dinner on an audit
date for the first time ever.
So that's it for
Policy Controller.
Make sure to check out
the description for links
to more resources on it.
And like and subscribe
to the channel
for more videos
about Google Cloud.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]